hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to some
more
kevin samuels you guys seem to like the
last one so i'm going to keep this
series going
before i start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
especially subscribe i'm trying to get
to 15k subscribers
so each and every one of you helps
okay so this video is titled kevin
samuels destroying women first six
minutes and 30
23 seconds straight i can't imagine this
is gonna go well
the one that impregnated you once or
twice
he he went to jail oh so
you pick ass whoopers and felons and
then you're gonna complain about what
other i need you to stop right here
ma'am i need you to slow down
i need you i need you to slow the whole
french toast down
i'm not gonna let you get on here and
talk about what black men are not when
you picking
dudes to whoop your ass and other felons
see i'm not gonna sit around and let you
black women just sit around talk about
black men ain't here and ain't this they
ain't dead when in your own life
you pick [ __ ] men want women
that's true i say this all the time like
if you pick bad men you can't be
complaining when they treat you bad
first time i get it you can complain you
have the option
to leave but you made a kid with them
who were fit but yet in our community 80
of the women are overweight and eighty
percent of that are obese it's that high
no one holds women accountable for their
weight so who's holding women
accountable
i'm sorry but who is going to get
liposuction
who's no no no no what the french toast
life just
eat less just eat less like it's not
that
crazy what sucks it's called push away
from the table drink water eat
vegetables
and exercise like a life
no man it's called exercise it is called
exercise that's true and i'm not the
thinnest either i
i struggle with food i totally get it
but
like i'm not going to make excuses i got
to get better how
then that means your femininity would be
number one
right that goes opposite to regression
opposite of aggression yes okay
aggression is masculine
so maybe i should turn off my cells when
i'm dating
i'm just telling you what high-value men
want is not aggressive females they want
feminine women
you may be successful in your career but
your education
your income does not increase your value
to men
your education and income may not but
i'm telling you i have brothers that
make good money
and they will dump girls because they
think they're dumb
like okay
i did a broadcast on that two three days
ago
men value your femininity and beauty
your fitness your submissiveness your
cooperation
your wound average man and average women
stand next to each other
you know what he has on you that you
don't have on him
time you got between ages 18 and 35 or
between
the first mitchell and 35 before you hit
high-risk pregnancy after 40
you cross over into no man's land
effectively
a man can be in his 60s and still if if
he
has the resources and the ability he can
still marry
young or even have kids i actually
am a little bit envious of guys for this
because i'm someone who like i really
want to develop like my career i want to
get my youtube channel started
but as a woman you always have that in
the back of your head like you only have
so much time man we know you only want
us to resources anyway so
the fact that you got to spend resources
to get a younger woman
yeah welcome to manhood even average
men are still they have inflated egos
and are still aiming for the eight
nine's intense
well there's a thing called math if
every black man who's available for
marriage
was married today there'd still be two
million of you left over
one in four of you were married in your
lifetime due respect
math is not on your side damn you didn't
just happen to have unprotected sex
and get pregnant that was a choice yes
so you got to start saying you got to
stop saying it just happened
that means it was a choice i do i did
want myself that's true
all right well then what i'm saying is
women need to stop saying it just
happened because that removes
accountability
oftentimes women use christianity as
convenient convenient christians
a woman's purpose is a man no no two
ways about it
women cannot survive without men you are
not physically
capable you don't have the strength your
body's not built for it
you cannot do it that's not
really true like women can survive like
in 2021 they could survive without men
i'm not saying that's the best option
for them but they definitely
can like this isn't the old days
so to say women can survive without men
is
telling women the wrong thing and as a
christian
you're actually telling women something
that goes opposite to what you say you
believe
and i just want to know is it really
over for women once they hit 30.
there is something called the wall
and the wall has everything to do with
every woman's fertility window
oh yeah absolutely at 35 the american
medical association
say that's when the average woman
reaches high-risk pregnancy
right right yeah so at age 30
is what me what is called the wall
because
women from 30 to 35 have a shortened
uh window to have what's considered to
lower risk pregnancy
and he comes home and says mama i'm
getting married to a woman with two kids
you're gonna say all right son i worked
all my life for you to go do that
you didn't raise your son and go through
all that for him to take over
some other person's bills yeah that's
true
if i were your husband how could i lead
you if you were if you're a boss
because of my schedule a box of my work
okay so again that's pedestalizing
and over inflating importance why is it
so important to
to make things sound so grand that are
just
common that's why i use the kids making
up a bed
yeah they feel good about it but in the
grand scheme of things
it ain't nothing and the damn show you
being the boss you want to pat on the
back for just average stuff
most women think of a high-value
lifestyle means your husband goes off to
work and brings home
hundreds of thousands of dollars and
you're sitting at home
playing making babies and playing house
no ma'am you're having to keep that
house running
you're gonna have to stay in shape fight
off competitors make sure
you're stay with your husband you know
you're saying all these things which
doesn't seem very hard to to
do really well how about listen listen
listen
no no listen don't over talk first thing
is you got to stay in shape
oh no no that's the number one thing
that most women can't do
speaking a lot about high earning men
who want to start families so what about
those
high earning men that don't want to have
children or high-earning men that
already have well
first off the ones that don't want to
have children don't want yours
they didn't want theirs they ain't gonna
want yours damn
oh my gosh uh i don't really have a lot
of comments on this
he's so harsh like
some of the stuff he says is definitely
true um
i'm a little bit more of like an
optimist so
i try to like look on the bright side of
things but
i do agree with him on a lot but let me
know in the comments do you agree do you
disagree
um either way let me know and don't
forget to like comment and subscribe bye
guys